welcome back to the morning toast i am
so excited to be sitting down with two
iconic queens iconic toasters and an
iconic moment happening right now you
guys it's carly and aaron hello carly
and aaron hi welcome to new york
taylor swift says welcome to new york
welcome to new york honestly
incredible you guys are so la like i
already i cannot picture you in new york
wait wait in what sense well just that
i'm right there just that you live there
like you're always like you know there
yeah yeah okay okay i get it not like
you're by at all because i haven't
gotten fake boobs yet no but i just
associate you guys with l.a neither of
you are actually from there no no full
transplants is anyone actually from l.a
i don't know i hate l.a i don't know how
you guys live there like it's like kind
of the vibe is it yeah
did you meet your fiance in l.a yeah
that's nice
yeah it's it's crazy though because his
parents actually grew up in the town
next to me
in massachusetts yeah we were like rival
towns that's crazy so friday night
lights east still in western i know but
then when he was like 10 months old they
moved him to park city so he grew up in
utah so you are from massachusetts and
you are from nebraska i am from nebraska
yes my little corn hustle every
quarterback do you eat a lot of corn
honestly not really that is so good
yeah i mean like it's fine if it's
around but i'm not like requesting corn
you're not i am i think corn is like the
best it honestly is it's so good
especially it's really good in la too
yeah they have like street corn that's
why i moved you know i'm more of like a
very basic on the cob girl like grilled
little butter salt like i don't like
people are making like a whole meal out
of corn when it's really a side dish
yeah a lot is really yummy canned corn
is also like a little sweet
so good really delish okay so can you
guys tell me i mean i know so much about
you guys because like i watch your vlogs
and i listen to your podcast but
you guys have like been in the game for
a while how old are you guys
30.
okay i'm 27. it's fine i'm like we're so
old like you're so pillow yes
um but how did you guys get how did you
guys meet each other
we met because of vine so when vine was
around back in our divine girlies yeah
we are viners oh my god i was obsessed
with mine oh my gosh it wasn't it was
the best it was the best do you think
it's better than tick-tock no i think
tick-tock is so much better oh obviously
my heart will always be with vines but
talk
is so much better
but yeah we met through mine and you
guys had group platforms on vine first
yeah and then i don't even remember
exactly how we met i think it was
because we okay so on vine even like
with tick tock you kind of like form
little communities of people we didn't
form like a hype house or anything right
on a smaller scale yeah we were just
forming friendships
um and i think that we had mutual
friends and then carly started like
watching like we started following each
other
and
i started following her because at the
time she had like bright pink hair and
looked like haley williams
you do look like haley williams thank
you so much that's such a compliment and
honestly someone brand for you guys like
emo night which we need to talk about we
need to talk yes we do and she would
like make like cute little like pair
more vines i was like oh i like this you
did yeah i'm sure you saw them like you
understand i was obsessed with mine and
i'm obsessed with tick tock too oh yeah
do you guys talk like you're you're
always coming up on my favorite pages
she's like a joker a talker oh oh yes i
was like i can talk sometimes i'm kind
of nervous right now
[Laughter]
yeah i love making tick tocks it's
literally like the greatest i don't
really like making them i like watching
them yeah same because like none of mine
getting good engagement like everyone
thinks i'm annoying on tick tock i i
can't get out of like i just can't find
success it's hard i mean it's weird
because sometimes something you don't
even care about will blow up on before
you pay you spent no time on no yeah
well i think the one sometimes you come
up on my for you page but the one that
made me really lol was the reba one you
did with theo yeah that would that
actually one did you do very well for me
yeah if you just knew like how much i
thought about tic tac every second of
every day and like for only me like 120
000 isn't nothing but it's not a lot and
like for that to be my legacy on this
earth like that's so upsetting
it is like it's nothing are you someone
who watches it for like hours before bed
i look up it's noon i
open my eyes at midnight like it's crazy
like the time just flies i know exactly
it's a problem well we now we're like
okay should we lay on the couch and
watch another show or should we get in
bed and watch tick tock by the way
that's a really really good point yeah
it's hard for me to watch shows because
i want halfway through i'm like i wonder
what's happening on today's so bad
totally it's so bad so good okay so you
were viners you met on vine and then
like when the day that vine like ended
it literally happened in like two days
what were you guys thinking because was
that your full-time jobs at the at the
time well we had kind of stopped posting
on the platform before it died because
it just kind of shifted and started
getting more really bad humor like so
bad popular page vines do you like ponds
oh yeah yeah i do like just kind of like
effects like girlfriend yeah totally
yeah big skits yeah we're like this is
just like
not for too weird now yeah and at that
point we had already lived in la and we
had started making youtube videos we did
a series called finding and driving
where we would like it's cute fake
interview other vine friends but we
played these like narcissists
narcissists that like would just like
make people do stuff for us i don't
really know if we were playing
characters but at the time probably not
honestly yeah um so that's kind of how
we got into youtube but so we had
already like kind of shifted
and then we were like oh well vine kind
of sucks now i also was still working
like a full nine-to-five job oh you were
yeah where i worked for my best friend's
dad i did like accounting stuff and i
was able to keep the job remote when i
moved to california oh that's so so i
trusted it when i was able to like pay
rent so did all the vlog squad members
meet pretty much from the vine days yeah
yeah that is so interesting we'd be out
filming with friends and aaron's boss
would call and she's like i'm just at
the grocery store i'll be back
hustling baby and like how old were you
when you officially quit your job and
did this full time
24 i want to say oh wow maybe
it was in 2017. so however old i was
then
got it it's like four years ago
yeah i don't know
i think it was 2017.
yeah i think so that's crazy i'll tell
you you could have told me 2012 i'd be
like sure i quit wearing one of those
t-shirts that has like the bathing suit
printed on oh yeah like you have like
the fake body yeah i had like a full
bone panic it was the worst i was just
watching her like good job because it's
always so hard like leaving jobs when
you're like connected to the people so
closely and like when you're taking a
risk like i'm sure everyone is like when
i graduated college and like didn't get
a job everyone was like she's a
delinquent i know and like because when
you're doing something new like people
don't understand it and then you're like
the crazy girl like who's taking a risk
and everybody in your hometown's talking
about you that was like literally fine
we'd like yeah divine meetups people
were like what the [ __ ] are you talking
you're meeting people online meeting
strangers oh girl 100 and we're like
yeah it's normal honestly whenever i
think about you too like i cannot
believe that you work together and
you're not related because like for me
and jackie like no matter what like at
the end of the day we're family that we
have to work things out we'll never like
break up you know because we're sisters
and we'll make we'll figure it out in
the end and we don't really get sick of
each other because we're sisters and
like that's just what like family does
so i'm in awe of people who work
together successfully
and don't break up and don't like want
to kill each other yeah yeah it's really
interesting i feel like we're just so
similar in a way where
we're both kind of go with the flow yeah
neither one of us is like causing an
issue ever it's funny too because we
we'll do like q and a sometimes we're
like what's your biggest fight and we're
like
i don't know like do you fight
no okay that's good not really i mean we
both also hate confrontation
just ignore it
the construction workers are obsessed
with us like they're constantly trying
to get us our attention and we won't
give in we will not give in i'll wave if
they need me too yeah show a titty
whatever you got to do i will
if it comes to that okay yeah okay so
back to you guys working together yeah
it's like
i feel like it's pretty easy i handle
most of like the business stuff and
carly likes doing all the editing and
like those kinds of things it's
important to delegate like yeah everyone
has their responsibilities and just to
kind of know your roles yeah and then if
like someone's doing like all the work
like the other person's like feeling
real like this it just gets really bad
when the responsibilities are not
delegated properly yeah that happened to
you ever um no in the beginning though
like when we first started like we we
didn't have good footing like i think
that we were all about like we were
either one of us was doing all of it at
one time then the other one was doing
all of it at one time and now we have
like like a clear delineation like what
the responsibilities are yeah and like
we like wrote it out when we launched
the toast after the morning breath was
canceled and we were like this is your
job this is my job and it's been the
same ever since because you just don't
want to feel like you're doing more than
the other person right you don't want to
feel like you're not being valued and so
it's important to communicate but it's
also so awkward yeah totally there's
definitely times where it's like well i
don't know i never feel like no i don't
either i feel like we just know what
we're doing yeah in terms of working no
you've got like down pat too yeah
so you do the podcast you do youtube
what do you like better
um it's so hard to say because we've
been doing youtube for so long now yeah
and i think over the panel here's a
better question what makes more
it
money
we probably i mean we make most of our
money with brand deals i would say on
youtube yeah yeah so that
that's a big part of it but right now i
like our podcast over youtube i think
because you need to put on makeup
what do you say did you have to put on
makeup well we don't well i
i don't really wear makeup ever anyway
like i feel like you're so beautiful
like that's why yeah just naturally not
everyone like has perfect freckles and
eyebrows got it i know it's so many i
think it's so annoying
i think that's what was like kind of
like our
strong thing in the beginning of youtube
as people were like oh they're not like
all done up and like right being like
like we were literally just like
relatable trash girls right more
authentic and i feel like it was emo
girls yeah and it was kind of before the
emma chamberlains yeah who are just like
perfect regardless or yeah or just being
completely themselves and just being
messy and whatever yeah and i feel like
most youtubers at the time were very
done up and like here's my beauty
routine yeah yeah which is fine but
we're just not it's not it yeah yeah so
i know you are like super into the emo
scene obviously we're going to talk
about emo night and i know your
husband's like a big into it did you
guys connect initially as emo girls like
are you an emo girly at heart a hundred
percent yeah like my hair is major emo
energy like it's crazy
wait really yes but do you think it's
because you know that about us no i'm
telling you like you're just like i
can't explain it
and i can't put my finger on it but you
are emo girlies like in a good way or
like
okay like an embarrassing way no in like
a haley williams way you real now that
now that you said it like i cannot look
at you and like oh my god thank you so
much she's so just keep thinking that i
know worse it's funny because i don't
feel like i look like her at all i just
feel like my hair did at the time and
now we're both i don't think she's
blonde anymore no it's you really do
look alike oh my god thank you no it's a
compliment she's so pretty okay have you
seen carly with pink hair no i have to
show you after because you'll be like
what have you ever tried your hair crazy
color yeah i did well i went like
platinum blonde you did the worst
decision of my life
um fried my hair and then i went purple
oh overtone has like this i don't know
if you've ever heard of that she's like
oh wow i know purple is brave i know it
luckily it wasn't like super bright so
that was good is this your natural hair
color yes i don't the last time i toned
it was
last november it's that rude question to
ask i feel like it is not asking someone
how old they are no i think i'm the same
where like i don't really have a filter
and like no out of control yeah i don't
control but i'll just ask people
questions you guys like you get it right
like i'm not going to say
um okay so we need to talk about emo
night because i swear to god it was the
best night of my life and it was i was
like so unwell like literally tripping
around the stage like i was just like so
excited full of adrenaline ben honestly
like he won't even look at me like he
thinks he's too good for me because he's
because he's a world famous dj okay so
just to give people some context you're
it's your fiance's like event right yes
so heath rose it's called emo knight la
but you do it all over yeah he does it
all over the country uh i want to say
it's like 20-plus cities now they've
also done some festivals overseas like
in london and stuff and so the night is
just like scheduled full of awesomeness
like you guys did a set ben did a set
there was a performer afterwards and
it's just like a real celebration of the
emo nest yeah in all of
genre and it's like avril lavigne it's
not even like particularly 90s it's like
really all emo music totally but they
really like keeping it current too like
at the la shows like they have lots of
um
uh
what is it called
like hip-hop like you know like little
peep like his uh no i don't know but
like machine gun kelly like yes he
really like keeps it's like current emo
yeah so like they try to keep the genre
like going and i feel like a lot of like
elder emos don't really appreciate that
because they're like that's not emo but
it's well
i actually that's a really good point
because i think that like the
one artist like responsible for ushering
emo into the 21st century and they don't
get enough credit it's five seconds of
summer oh okay are you like heart i
agree
cause i've got a jet black it's hard i
literally rock out with my [ __ ] out like
so good and you know me and ben they've
been to emo night you're lying no yeah i
don't understand i'm obsessed they're
saying
you'll see all the like emos like come
out oh my god okay because they invented
the like celebrities me and ben drove
two hours like 10 years ago to so go see
five seconds of summer and this was like
when they they opened for one direction
and they're like yeah they were like
really like for teenagers and so me and
ben get to the concert it's like people
with their parents like it's me and men
are the oldest people there and like the
tickets were so cheap because all kids
were like sitting the first row it was
the best night of our lives they're so
talented yeah yeah i agree it's so nice
to talk to people who like can
appreciate oh yeah did you like one
direction too obsessed okay good because
they're like the pop punk version of one
direction basically well one of like my
kind of
reasons why i feel like i'm better than
everyone else is because when i was in
college i went to met life stadium and i
saw five seconds of summer open up for
one direction and it was
it's pretty iconic there were no words
like honestly better than words
that was beautiful aaron thank you so
much so even i was just like i can't
really even explain and that's like
becoming really popular i'm seeing all
over tik tok these like themed nights
out like taylor swift
and i think it's so brilliant such a
good like i can't believe i didn't think
of it first it's like the best business
idea ever like i can't know i don't ever
want to go out again if it's not email
it's a theme tonight yeah i know you
just have to go to every city
you can do like a bucket list yes
but i would say like
new york is always so fun it's
particularly hard to get artists right
now just because like everyone's
starting to get back on the road and
like covet and all of those things but
they've done some really cool stuff at
webster before it was the best night
ever
you guys did a set yeah and like how
many times a year do you do a set like
seeing you guys up there i was like you
guys are just kidding you guys look so
cool like
i was just like this is like everything
like you guys look sick you address the
part thank you so much it's funny
because well i don't know if you know
but she met tj like we went to emanate
before she even knew tj yeah oh my god
is that where you met
um
sort of so
tj is her fiance yeah she's a covered
bride she doesn't want to talk about it
i don't um
so we had gone to like one emo night and
then obsessed by the first one yeah of
course so so much well because friends
were like oh you guys will love this
night you have to come you're so emo so
it was like our friends already lived in
la and the party had been happening i
want to say for like six months so it
had like kind of just started and so we
went we had like the best time it was
actually funny because we had just gone
to the taylor swift
um 1989 tour like the night before
that's really still on her like glow
wristband wait i don't remember this
story you had on your glow wristband and
tj had actually gone we obviously didn't
know this at the time but he had gone
the night before we went i love a man
who respects taylor swift oh i know so
important
why do you think i married it
the only reason are you guys married we
were legally married just because we
thought like the handmaid's tale was
going to happen and that was the best
thing yeah and our wedding is in a few
months so also your drink was very
strong i started inviting literally
everyone i saw to the what i invited ben
actually you did you guys are booked not
be there so you already have oh wait
also you have to officiate her that's
okay sure do you need me to sing an a
cappella acoustic version of toast yes
okay
would you like music do you guys sing
no you don't i feel like you would no i
feel like any youtuber you kept singing
so it's like fine they could figure it
out james charles can do it
yes i mean every youtuber literally you
guys i feel like i've met so many famous
people like through the vlog squad like
who's the most famous person you met
probably justin bieber were you in the
car for that segment yeah it's so funny
because we got like paparazzi after
and like we don't really think about it
like that but then like i didn't even
know that happened and then i had
friends sending me pictures and we're
like what's happening what is the
selection process like obviously there's
so many members in the vlog squad like
but you know only three people can fit
in the tesla if someone's sitting in the
front seat totally who what's the
selection process like it depends on the
bit like i feel like a lot of the times
like there's some people who can be like
very overwhelming if it like around
justin bieber like it could be really
overwhelming we're like we're just kind
of like chill yeah you guys are like in
my opinion the most low-key members
thank you
i'm honestly i i want to say i'm a carly
and aaron but like i'm kind of a zane
that's fair i feel that too i just like
am like i'm always just like the
drunkest oh yes and like center of
attention
yeah if i had first of all if i had to
put a finger on like which one yeah but
i'm also like a carly and aaron like
fusion
carly aaron like zayn well probably like
zayn is your rate actually zayn is
28. okay same thing turning 29 i think
in november i'm still 27 so i feel like
like when you get a little older yeah i
think i think we went out of our zane
phase well you were i was a zane at one
point actually i was by the way
all i think we're all a zane yeah at
some point yeah so i know it's like
everyone goes through like a zayn phase
yeah so you guys have been on the
internet for like ever now
do you feel like you go back and watch
some of your old content and like want
to die
every day okay kind of i don't well
sometimes even like videos we film like
i don't want to watch that one like a
full johnny depp current one yes you
mean especially over the pandemic
because we filmed separately and we
posted at the time three videos a week i
remember that i watched that oh my god
please don't watch that like by the way
me and jackie like we cannot talk about
zoom toast like it's filled with trauma
yes and we just we don't even
acknowledge it's like if she knows i
brought it up she'll be mad like we
don't talk about it would you rather so
bad is it like you'd rather just not
even do it if it's over zoom well so the
thing is is like we so our episodes are
video and audio but most of the people
listen as podcasts so like the video is
always just like an added bonus for us
because we like to like you know be on
camera yeah and so during the pandemic
at first we were just recording audio
which is easy from home we have great
whatever totally and everyone's like we
want to see your face and we're like you
know what like we have to make the most
of the pandemic so we're like we'll
record on zoom yeah
and like i don't know i can't explain
why just like everything about it was
like disgusting no it is i i [ __ ]
hate zoom i have so much trauma like
from that time like i don't i i will not
hop on a zoom call like i'm a skype girl
now like i just can't just call me on
the phone please you know like facetime
me like i cannot go on zoom i know it's
so crazy to me that like so many people
are still having to use it yeah but you
guys also did a really good job like
with the editing and all that
with the zoom episodes we kind of had to
figure it out i feel like we did zoom
for like a few months and then we're
like okay we can actually just like
be on zoom but then film it with a
different camera so that way it doesn't
look like we're right that's the key
that's the case it was like such i
became a producer
do you guys continue to come up with new
ideas for your for for your um youtube
videos i don't know
i think that's why we are enjoying the
podcast more because we have been doing
it for so long we posted three times a
week like it's always so easy when we're
just like around our group of friends of
course like the condo is happening
yep and that's kind of what our videos
have always been i feel like during the
pandemic they shifted to more of like a
traditional youtube like
what is my voice my boyfriend styles me
like those kind of like cheesier videos
um so that was kind of traumatic
um but now it's really really hard
especially because during the pandemic
we did that for like a year plus right
and we're just like we wind up dropping
a video so now we only post two times a
week you know sometimes it's better like
quad quantity over quantity yeah agreed
it's just tough on youtube though
because
i feel like if you don't post for maybe
even like two weeks no you're irrelevant
people don't care yeah i don't know how
true that is but it just feels like that
i just feel well that's like the thing
it's like a rat race in the space it's
like we podcast every day i'm like i
think we should move to twice a day like
because you just want to be like the
most curious oh my god please do
like you it's actually like so toxic on
your mental health to like constantly be
keeping up and you see everyone else
like doing more videos and they hire
editors and they have a whole team so
you want to do that too but it's like
when can i live i know i know can i live
i know it's also people being like
youtube isn't relevant anymore instagram
is so that's moronic i don't like that
that [ __ ] doesn't bother me because
those people are like so jealous of us i
know it's really funny too because like
every day comments what are you gonna do
when this ends like what do you why
don't you get a real job people have
been asking me that like since i
graduated college like oh yeah i think i
think we're here to stay no yeah no you
guys are good it's like do you ask
people when their job is going to be
over no it's moronic like when you're
getting fired for being lazy
yeah
um do you guys keep up with youtuber
drama at all because you're like
youtubers and like you i feel like
you're always like filming with other
youtubers we 100 keep up with okay so
like what are your thoughts on this like
frenemies things like that's like
here we go and also like you guys like
have met and hung out with trish because
she used to date someone in the box
squad right yes yes um i guess i'm just
not surprised that it happened yeah i
guess i think it was kind of a thing for
us we were like
this is going to go wrong at some point
yeah and
we're we were kind of just waiting for
that to happen do you know ethan
no like we knocked out of nowhere like
who is he i never heard of it well carly
you had like watched their podcast yeah
i used to really like age three i just
and i always said him and his wife yes
and they did interviews with like bo
burnham and comedian like bill burns
stuff like that so i always really liked
them but
yeah i don't really know him at all no
it's just watching somebody that was the
craziest drama like oh my god totally
it was really mind-blowing no i was like
living for every single moment of it
what are you guys thoughts on jeffree
star
i don't know i don't really understand
has you ever ever filmed in the vlog
squad
um i think yeah david and jason filmed
with him a little bit dude
it was just like a vlog i think right is
that when he was with tricia because i
remember seeing that yeah they were
still friends and jason was dating
tricia and they went to jeffries i don't
know if they ever
i think they filmed but like they never
posted it i think that's like a little
bit in his video but i remember they did
like a bit more i thought maybe
but i don't we never met him and then
like the shane dawson of it all like
were you guys watching that documentary
that they were doing like shane and yeah
jeffrey yes oh so good
the makeup yeah yeah i mean that was
iconic it was literally like i can't
believe i was alive for that and like
now like both of them are like like i
never hear about jeffrey anymore i never
hear about shane like jeffrey's like
living in wyoming and like shane
moved home like oh yeah they moved to
colorado oh right like like close island
yeah ryland's family yeah and so it's
like
i don't know i feel like like three
years ago was like the golden age of
youtube like where all those people go i
know i know they're so low key now i
know i guess that's what happens when
you make a lot of money i guess which is
probably nice for that totally i think
you've got to make a lot of money it's
like that and like cancellation yeah of
course i mean you can't don't want to
get canceled again like please not not
manifesting that for us or anyone here
we are nice people please we are good
leave us alone
but definitely like need to buy a ranch
in wyoming it's on my bucket list a
thousand percent wait i wanted to ask
maybe
i shouldn't but you mentioned that you
guys go to utah every year what part uh
we stay all over like we've been to park
city
we went to deer valley like usually in
that area okay within like an hour from
the airport pretty much fun but i just
love it it's the best oh my god i'm
literally gonna start an only fan so
that i can make money to buy property
you know if i cannot get like a branch
in utah in the next 10 years like i
don't want i don't want to be here
anymore
i'm absolutely kidding myself
literally
our fiancee's from is that reason so he
grew up in park city so you get to go
back
yeah but it's so sad because his parents
he had like the most
stunning house and then in 2017 they
sold it and then they bought a house on
cape cod
and then they spend the winters in utah
so it's like nice because we get to go
back all the time yeah probably like
close to do you know ogden at all
no yeah it's like that the outskirts
yeah it's like small towns um
and so they have like a condo at the top
of a ski resort that's like from the 80s
it's really ski and ski out it's so nice
so we go like every winter it was really
ski yeah but i learned oh i can't while
i
i went
i would die
like to learn that's so funny and i have
to say like i can't actually recall a
worst day of my life i love tj teach you
he's really good and patient and like i
honestly was like this will probably
make her break our relationship and it
okay but the thing is it wasn't even
about the teacher it wasn't about the
circumstances it's just like my body
like my legs were killing me yeah like
my shins like from the boots were on so
tight my all my weight is like on my
shins and i was like
who enjoys this like i like to
snowmobile it's oh my god so [ __ ] you
just get to sit sit sounds like a jet
ski it's so much better yeah and
actually you do engage your core quite a
bit oh do you you do because it's like
there's tension and like yeah actually
like when it i'm not even making this up
like your stomach like does hurt
afterwards there is like something like
um what is that like cool sculpting
exactly
the whole time so now that you've been
in new york for three days like would
you ever live here
well i have like oh we've always wanted
to probably relocate here and be by
coastal just because like i can't do
winter anymore i grew up with winters
and like i'm just not here for it unless
it's going to park city or like montana
right like the hallmark channel vibes
yeah it's like i'll go there for a few
weeks and then it's done i don't have to
worry about cleaning off my car and like
schlepping all over the place i'm just
not here for that yeah like i literally
left massachusetts the year we had like
106 inches of snow and i was like oh my
god yeah so i feel like it's like i
would love to live here during like the
summer fall and then go back to la for
like
winter do you have some apartments or
houses in l.a i just bought a house in
january actually you did
yeah i just bought a condo we bought it
at it sounds so homeowners look at you
yeah it's no big deal yeah look at a
real job
right right yeah when the internet's
like done with us
yeah oh my god you guys bought houses
that's crazy are you ever afraid like
someone's just my own i've always lived
in an apartment and like yeah i think
with the house is like someone could
just like walk in the door like do you
ever feel like it's literally my biggest
family okay cameras on every available
entrance like but even still at night
i'm like lock them no that would like
kill me
yeah yeah it's nice though because we're
in like where we are we lived in like
hollywood-ish area for like three and a
half years and i was like done yeah
moving to the suburbs
um the suburbs so we moved to the valley
the suburbs that's where the vanderpump
rules kids live it's yeah we live so
close to all did you see them
i've never seen that but they've also
been to emo night you're lying i swear
to god i've gotta go to when's the emo
night la next one it's the first two uh
friday of every month they used to do it
oh my god it's like the first monday in
may the first friday of every month yeah
i'll be there seriously every month
every single month where is it where is
that um it's in echo park okay whatever
lincoln park after dark
go to nail polish stuff this is
literally the first time i switched
these are gonna this is gonna be my
wedding nail colors you're doing black
nails for your wedding so no this is um
guys and galaxies but typically always i
o so instead of like the purple
undertone of lincoln park after dark
this is like a maroon okay it's black
that's how i like i'm like it's black
yeah for sure it's black
thank you for showing me your black
nails thank you both so much for being
here everyone make sure to check out
their podcast only friends which is such
a good name for a podcast i can't wait
to get myself first um amazing youtube
channel follow them on instagram aaron
it's just aaron gilfoy and carly and
contro right yes yeah thank you guys so
much for being here
and a half i hope i didn't talk over you
too much oh my god no that's like my
thing my thing too i always talk about
carly and everyone yells at me no
literally like then you're jackie and
you're me like
i'm an animal and i i'm trying to be
conscious of it and i'm incapable of
being it's hard yeah
it's so hard but i love you guys thank
you so much for being here thank you
thank you guys for watching and we'll
see you tomorrow bye